if you if you've done it to a lot
if I let you just go there I don't
remember going to get him if he gets
quick that he's younger than me he's
gonna fly around there but if I just
wish
so I'm gonna just put my elbow and go to
that window with my elbow
that gives me a little bit longer
nice
okay
I just push him out
messed up
okay so you can't do sheer Navy
um
it's the worst thing I know about you
teachers because when you want to start
you start thinking half the way through
teachings showing something
and your brain goes why did I why did I
start thinking it's the worst thing you
do okay so this as he comes
as he comes I just do that
much
it just gets him so look yeah and I do a
HAPO Geary with my feet
so here